europe
you know that thing belgium is in if if
you've watched the news at all lately
you cannot have missed what has been
happening there
europe's migrant crisis is getting worse
by the day a migrant crisis spiraling
out of control
hundreds of thousands of asylum seekers
are risking everything a human wave
washing over europe's southern shores
hundreds of thousands of migrants have
streamed into europe
the largest influx there since the end
of world war ii
wow the largest since the end of world
war ii and remember
millions of people back then were
searching both for a better life
and for the booth where it was rumored
you could slap dead hitler
and look the scale of this story can be
hard to get your head around
hundreds of thousands of people are on
the move just within europe and another
four million
are being hosted in turkey lebanon and
jordan and when numbers get that high
they can be hard to comprehend it's like
when someone tells you the size of the
audience of ncis new orleans
17 million people how's that even
possible
how many navy-based crimes could there
possibly be in new orleans
this doesn't make any sense
and when you are dealing with a mass of
people that large
you really want to be a little careful
with how you describe them
unfortunately david cameron noted
alleged swine fellatio enthusiast
recently referred to a swarm of people
coming across the mediterranean and that
language
matters because a swarm of anything
sounds terrifying no matter what it is
if i hear there are a lot of kittens
coming my way
i'm going to be delighted but if i hear
there is a swarm of kittens approaching
i'm grabbing a shotgun and i'm getting
to high ground because i'm not going to
let those furry take me alive
and here and
and here in the u.s some in the media
have chosen to reduce the migrant
population to one
simple stereotype a new video surfaces
online showing
why some are worried europe is opening
its doors to potential terrorists
those are reportedly muslim refugees on
a train in europe chanting allah akbar
or
god is great now to be clear we're not
saying that any of those people are
terrorists or in any way affiliated with
a terror group but
it does highlight just how many of these
refugees who are fleeing violence in
iraq and syria
are muslim okay okay
first you don't get to claim that you're
not calling those people
terrorists when your lower third says
terrorists inbound question mark
if you are really not saying they're
terrorists maybe change that to
something more accurate like
people take train or some wear hats
others less so and second
describing that as a new video that
sheds light on the migrant crisis
is a little misleading because in
researching this story we found a
version of that same video uploaded onto
youtube
back in 2010 well before this migrant
crisis
even began and if you are going to use
misleading old footage
to try and make people frightened of
muslims why stop there
just go the whole way and use a clip
from true lies
now to be clear we're not saying that
any of those people are terrorists or in
any way affiliated with a terror group
but
it does highlight just how many of these
refugees who are fleeing violence in
iraq and syria
are muslims that's that's only about 10
percent more
racist than what you did so look
let's just take a step back because for
the record these people are coming from
many different countries and fleeing
everything from civil war
to economic stagnation and while each
story is unique
many of them are heartbreaking nojin is
16 and from cabane
in syria disabled from birth she cannot
walk
and made the dangerous crossing from
turkey last week i've been
trying many things for for the first
time during this journey like a train
and a ship
so i i just enjoyed it i didn't
you enjoyed it yeah you're the first
person i've met who said that
but to understand why you must know the
world she escaped from
imagine you're 16 and you're always
afraid to be dead
at any minute what is your dream
i have to be an astronaut to go out and
see
and find an alien yes
so i want to meet the queen
yes oh i think that girl absolutely
deserves to meet an alien and the queen
and also if she has time a real human
with feelings
but unfortunately for najin and
so many like her europe has yet to
create an effective system to process
this influx of people
every country has a different
application process and some are totally
overwhelmed and underfunded
we actually got our hands on a couple of
registration forms
that were given to refugees upon arrival
this one was handed to a syrian asylum
seeker arriving in greece on september
the 5th
it tells him to return for registration
on december
the 21st and that could be a tricky
three-month wait
because he's not allowed to work in that
time and yet that is nothing compared to
this form
given to an iraqi refugee in turkey
telling him to come back on june 15th
of 2017 which sounds bad
before you notice the pink sticky notes
added at the bottom clarifying that his
actual date
will be february 19 2020 and that is
ridiculous
these people can't go five years without
working
they're refugees not renee zellweger
and and facing that kind of limbo
it's no wonder refugees want to try to
push deeper into europe and many of them
are heading for one surprising country
in particular that seems to actually
want them
they keep coming thousands every day at
the main train station in munich
often greeted by applauding locals or
welcoming volunteers
it's no wonder that germany is the
preferred destination for so many
refugees
that's right amazingly one of the
warmest welcomes on offer to immigrants
comes from
germany a country whose idea of a
bedtime story is two children being left
to die in the forest
before being nearly cooked and eaten and
then murdering an old woman
sleep well unfortunately
many politicians in other countries in
germany have been
actively hostile to anyone even
considering settling within their
borders
no way you will not make the netherlands
home
please don't come it's risky to come
we can't guarantee that you will be
accepted here the danish government has
published these
ads in a number of lebanese newspapers
the text
is obviously written in arabic and it's
telling migrants
don't come to denmark highlighting the
tough regulations and constraints that
await them there
that's right denmark is so averse to
taking people in it's basically
placing intentionally missed connections
ads in other countries
me danish government official you person
in a lebanese refugee camp
from the moment i saw you i knew there
was nothing between us and it could
never work
perfect send but even
denmark's approach seems friendly next
to the video apparently produced
by the mayor of ashitalam in hungary
showing exactly how he
and his police forces would prevent
migrants from coming to his town
moderate sag ross vallo stash
ashot allegro
[Music]
okay okay a few things there first
you can add as much scary music as you
want there is nothing imposing about
one van driving alone on a country road
the only message that that is sending to
migrants is make sure you wait for that
one van to pass by
and second of all mr mayor you do
realize that border police and nightclub
bouncers are not the same thing right
you look like you're about to throw
someone out of hungary because they
didn't bring enough hot girls with them
and that mayor is no outlier hungary has
been responsible for some of the ugliest
mistreatment of refugees in europe
disturbing cell phone video appears to
show migrants at the main refugee camp
here being fed like a herd of caged
animals in a holding pen
it's a shocking video that has garnered
attention from around the world
as waves of desperate migrants sprint
from a holding camp in hungary
a camerawoman appears to trip a man
running with his
child in his arms the woman also kicks
other migrants as they run
including a young girl now the
camerawoman is out of a job
oh i'm sorry she lost her job that's
absolutely terrible
don't worry i'm sure she can find a new
one on actualmonster.com
to be fair she later apologized saying
i'm not a heartless racist children
kicking camera woman
which i can only presume means she's a
loving accepting children kicking camera
woman
because the children kicking part is not
really up for debate anymore
and even those countries who are
offering to take refugees
are sometimes making those offers in the
most insultingly selective way
slovakians saying that they're only
going to give asylum to uh
to christians they don't want uh muslims
uh migrants coming into the country
muslim asylum seekers
not least because they haven't got any
mosques
oh i'm sorry slovakia you can't take
muslims in because you don't have any
mosques
you do know you can build those right
mosques don't
naturally occur in the wild due to
erosion
or particularly devout beavers
muslims muslims can live anywhere
that other humans can live muslims are
not like dolphins trying to resettle in
scottsdale arizona
and when refugees are not being excluded
on the basis of religion they're being
accused of being lazy freeloaders just
listen to one polish mep
addressed the european parliament
if we abolish all benefits then people
who don't want to work
and want to live from benefits wouldn't
come to poland and the rest of europe
people who want to work are precious
however they are sent back
and we accept only those who don't want
to work it's ridiculous policy leading
to invasion of human trash
let us be clear human trash human
garbage
that doesn't want to work human garbage
those are some pretty strong words
coming from the polish six flags guy
and and what what he said is not just
offensive it's also wrong
research has shown that while there is
some small cost in the short term
eventually an influx of lower-wage
immigrants into a community
tends to raise wages for everyone else
and a working paper published last year
by four economists found
that immigration benefited local
populations in 19
of the 20 industrialized countries they
studied and think about that
adding immigrants makes things better 19
times out of 20.
that's a success rate matched only by
bacon and paul rudd
and incidentally it's it's just a little
hard to hear these migrants and refugees
being called
lazy considering how hard many of them
have worked to reach europe in the first
place
you really want to talk about lazy
migrants i'm a lazy migrant
i left a country by airplane and the
only things i was escaping were fog
public indifference and an almost
certain future as the turtle of prince
harry's entourage
i didn't want to be royal turkey i
didn't want to be royal turkey
and the maddening thing the maddening
thing here is
europe doesn't even need to do this for
good reasons it can do it for selfish
ones because as a continent it is in
dire
need of new citizens according to the un
the average woman needs to have
2.1 children to maintain the population
of a developed country
but in the european union every single
country
is below that 2.1 level by 2050
some countries like greece portugal and
germany will see their populations drop
by
double-digit percentages according to
pew
that's true if europe doesn't open its
doors to more migrants
this is not the changing face of europe
they should be frightened of
this is this one right here and look
not every single asylum seeker is going
to be the perfect economic wellspring
but instead of
worrying about the hypothetical downside
of letting these migrants in
countries should be more worried about
the actual downside of turning them away
if for no other reason that you might
miss out on someone like najin
who seems like she would improve any
country that would have her
just listen to how she taught herself
english how did you learn to speak such
a good idea
at home with my favorite tv show
what's that it's the days of our lives
with
for this sunday struggle
yeah i love them both how could you not
want this girl in your country
she loves days of our lives she loves it
she loves faith in our lives and
specifically
she loves ej and sammy in fact even
after weeks of total hell
mortal danger and inhumane treatment
najin's biggest complaint
is that the show actually killed off ej
who was her favorite character
and frankly she's right to be upset ej
and sammy were
magic together i mean yes you could
argue that ej basically blackmailed
sammy into marriage
and then impregnated her and then worked
for sami's arch-nemesis
nicole walker who he then also
impregnated
and then he kidnapped sammy's baby and
made her think it was dead so sammy
shot him in their head but you know what
that's the kind of thing couples do
and besides they got through all that
and yes yes sure ej did then
cheat on sammy before their wedding with
that trollope abigail devereaux
but but he still didn't deserve to die
from yet another gunshot wound even
though yes it was
at best reckless for him to have a
secret meeting with hillbilly drug lord
clyde weston in the middle of the
woods
you idiot ej how could you die
you and sammy were so close to eternal
happiness why ej why
why ej my point is
my point is my point is
najin has been through enough and any
country would be lucky to have her
and i know lots of people still have
fears fears that migrants will bankrupt
social systems which many studies show
does not happen
fears that migrants might have an isis
member lurking among them which there
has been
no credible example of and no one is
saying this is easy
but the fact is so hard it's not a
reason to do less it's a reason to do
more from countries expediting their
application process
to properly funding the un high
commission for refugees whose fund for
responding to syrian refugees in
neighbouring countries
is less than half of where it needs to
be to simply
and i know this sounds crazy just not
kicking them when they're moving around
and and there's it's a crazy idea
just rain your legging and there is
actually one final thing
that we thought we could do and it is
admittedly very small and it is just for
one
refugee but for najin who was so
justifiably saddened
by the death of ej from days of our
lives we made some calls
and we have a surprise that is literally
just for you
[Music]
no way no it's not it's me it can't be
trouble
[Music]
it's you oh
not even my father would let me die in a
pile of debt my sister made sure that i
survived the morgue and then she flew me
to germany where my father's witch
doctors did their work
physically i've been in love for months
but it took me a long time to be able to
get away from him and his people
after my resurrection
[Music]
i just can't imagine how horrible this
was for you
it was nothing coming back from the dead
that's not hard
you know what's hard getting from syria
to germany
oh have you seen what those migrants are
going through
it's insane a thousand dollars to bribe
your way onto a rubber dinghy and that's
how you get across the mediterranean and
if you make it to the border of turkey
they'll
hand you a form offering you an
appointment five years from now and then
if you're lucky you get to navigate a
barrage of bigotry and hatred from some
mayors in hungary
it's horrible someone tripping a child
if someone did that to my child
you slapped him twice
you know there are some amazing people
coming through that border
i read about this incredible 16 year old
girl from gabbani called najin mustafa
najin mustafa yes eugene mustafa
maybe we got to meet her one day
right now you are not going anywhere